en el último vídeo nombramos a tres muy
sencillos en este vídeo vamos a ver unos
ligeramente más complicados y en
particular qué pasa si en el proceso de
tener un éter tenemos tenemos un anillo
en lugar de sólo una cadena larga así
que puedes imaginar una molécula que se
vea algo así tienes tu oxígeno en este
lado del oxígeno tienes esta cadena de
carbonos aquí tienes una cadena de
carbonos como esto pero luego esa cadena
enlaza nuevamente al oxígeno por lo que
tenemos un anillo aquí y no es obvio
cómo nombrar esto no puedes solo ver
este lado y llamarlo metil y luego ese
lado y llamarlo metil también es el
mismo lado se conecta a sí mismo así que
como nombras este tipo de éter
lo que tienes que hacer es solo enumerar
lo los números números la cadena de
carbonos más larga como siempre hemos
hecho en el caso de un al canon así que
esto es y podemos empezar a enumerar
aquí tenemos 1 2
y entonces esto si sólo pensamos en la
cadena de carbonos si tenemos sólo un
carbono su prefijo smet 2 es ed
es prop 4 es wood por lo que si esto
sólo fuera una cadena de carbonos lo
llamaríamos butano por lo que si solo
vemos si sólo observamos esta cadena de
carbonos de aquí
esta cadena de carbonos llamarías a esto
butano llamarías a esto
blue
no
pero obviamente esto no es butano tienes
este oxígeno enlazado a los carbonos 1 y
4 del butano por lo que para aclarar eso
llamamos a esto llamamos a esto y déjame
resaltó esta parte de aquí ese oxígeno
de ahí está enlazado a los carbonos 1 y
4 por lo que llamamos a esto 1,4
y esta es la nueva palabra que
aprenderemos en este vídeo 14
sí
butano 14 epoxy butano y esto no solo
aplica cuando el éter forma un anillo
largo de hecho puede formar un pequeño
anillo dentro de una cadena regular así
que podrías imaginarte algo como esto
déjame dibujar una cadena de carbonos
digamos que tenemos 5 carbonos 1 2 3
de esta manera y luego digamos que entre
este carbono y este carbono en lugar de
tener un enlace doble este carbono de
hecho se enlaza con un oxígeno que luego
se une a este carbono de aquí y
obviamente cada carbono tiene cuatro
enlaces que no se dibujaron estos son
hidrógenos como nombramos esto
se hace con el mismo proceso empezamos a
numerar de hecho empezamos a numerar la
cadena donde el oxígeno está enlazado
así que empezaremos a numerar en este
extremo de aquí tenemos 1
5 por lo que esto es venta no esto es
no
y luego el oxígeno está unido a los
carbonos 1 y 2 por lo que llamamos a
esto 12 epoxy pentano 1,2
por qué
epoxy pentano ahora en el último vídeo
les dije que en general los tres son
poco reactivos de hecho son buenos
disolventes pero lo que acabo de dibujar
aquí es un caso especial de tres
llamados epoxi dos cuando solo tienes
este tipo de sólo tres y una cadena de
tres átomos aquí son dos carbonos y un
oxígeno este es un caso especial de un
éter llamado epoxi do esto se llama
por si tú
y esto a diferencia de la mayoría de los
seres es muy reactivo
esto es
muy
tipo
otra manera de pensar en eso es decir
que es muy inestable esto es muy esto es
muy reactivo por eso algunas personas
consideran esto como algo aparte de los
seres y la razón por la cual son muy
reactivos es por este anillo de tres
miembros de aquí hay mucha deformación
en estos enlaces estos electrones a
estos enlaces no les gusta estar tan
cerca unos de otros si quisieras hacerlo
con un modelo un modelo con moléculas
tendrás problemas en doblar lo
suficiente en las uniones para de hecho
a hacer este enlace así que este es muy
muy muy inestable y de hecho hay una
manera alternativa de nombrar epoxy 2 la
manera alterna y esta es una manera
totalmente legítima de nombrarlos puedes
nombrarlos como un éter con un anillo
esto es 12 epoxy pentano la manera
alterna es pretender que tienes como un
doble enlace
que en lugar de este oxígeno de aquí
tienes un enlace doble si tienes un
enlace doble esto esto se llamará esto
se llamará y dependiendo de cómo quieras
nombrarlo puedes llamarlo uno centeno
no este es como si no hubiera un oxígeno
aquí pero si un doble enlace 120 no se
vería algo así
este es el carbono 1
así que tenemos uno
esto es como 120 no se vería aprendimos
eso muchos muchos vídeos atrás algunas
veces se nombra como paint uno en o
dependiendo de la convención esta es una
de las más comunes pero tenemos este
oxígeno aquí en lugar de este doble
enlace
tenemos este oxígeno aquí en lugar de
este doble enlace por lo que en lugar de
solo llamarlo 120 no lo llamamos
óxido d
y un nuevo puente no los llamamos
óxido
ha sido
120 no óxido de 120 no justo así por lo
que estos dos son los nombres para
exactamente la misma molécula esto
aclara que es una époc sido un tipo
especial de éter que es más reactivo
esto es sólo una manera general en la
que nombramos cualquier tipo de éter
cíclico
así que hagamos uno más para dejarlo más
claro tenemos un ciclo que se desvía de
un ciclo tengamos un óxido que sale de
otro anillo solo para dejar esto claro
estos son bastante complicados de
nombrar la primera vez siempre es un
poco confusa
así que tenemos un anillo ciclohexano
por aquí
esto es un ciclo hexano pero digamos que
tenemos un pequeño el óxido
ramificándose de esta manera justo así
eso es lo que está pasando así que si
queremos aclarar que esto es un epoxi do
tenemos que esencialmente pretender
primero pretender que esto es sólo un
enlace doble y si esto es sólo un doble
enlace esto sólo será un ciclo externo
esto sería un ciclo externo
cloud
si este oxígeno no estuviera ahí y en
lugar de eso solo tuviéramos un enlace
doble aquí no tienes que especificar el
número cuando solo tienes un doble
enlace en un ciclo externo porque podría
estar en cualquier lado y esencialmente
sería la misma molécula pero ya que
tenemos este oxígeno aquí en lugar de un
enlace doble que está unido a estos dos
carbonos llamamos a este óxido de ciclo
externo ciclo externo
esta parte de aquí
hace que esto se llame
óxido
ciclo exe no o si queremos sólo nombrar
esto como uno tradicional como un éter
tradicional la manera en la que lo
haríamos
nombraremos esto
solo nombraremos esto solo nombraremos
esto ciclohexano ciclohexano
sí claro
exacto
y poniendo epoxy delante de él y
poniendo epoxy
x
si cualquiera de los dos es válido y una
vez más no tienes que enumerar lo porque
podrías llamarlo 12 epoxy ciclohexano si
haces a este el carbono 1
2 pero sabes que va a estar en carbonos
adyacentes y pudo haber estado en
cualquiera de estos dos pudo haber
estado en el 3 y en el 4 y esencialmente
sería la misma molécula por lo que de
hecho esto hace más clara la estructura
de la molécula pero de todas maneras
espero que lo hayas disfrutado y en el
siguiente vídeo
de hecho te mencioné que los epoxy 2 son
reactivos por lo que me gustaría
mostrarte una reacción tratando con
epoxy 2